pues definitivamente en Nevada en
Arizona es donde se está demorando la
elección para definir quién se queda con
la mayoría en cámara de representantes y
senado de hecho medios locales están
diciendo que Precisamente en Arizona
quedan todavía 300.000 votos por contar
sobre todo en el condado de maricopa muy
cercano a la ciudad de Phoenix donde
votaron muchas personas y lo hicieron
por correo pero en vez de enviar ese
voto por correo de forma anticipada pues
llevaron su sobre el mismo día de la
lección y esto ha demorado el conteo en
ese estado las cosas están de la
siguiente forma el senado en este
momento los demócratas tienen 48 escaños
los republicanos 49 en el senado
Precisamente lo que están diciendo los
pronósticos es que Nevada pues va a ser
un estado que van a ganar los
republicanos el republicano va a ganar
ese estado según las proyecciones
Arizona a pesar de que no se ha
terminado de contar la mayoría de los
votos le dan ese estado a los demócratas
al demócratas Entonces la cosa quedaría
dependiendo únicamente de lo que pase en
Georgia porque recordemos que de haber
un empate 50 escaños republicanos 50
demócratas el voto el escaño de la
vicepresidenta Harris es el que le daría
la mayoría Entonces al partido demócrata
en cuanto a la cámara en este momento
los demócratas tienen aseguradas 200 4
sillas los republicanos 211 sillas están
muy cerca lograr esa cifra mágica de 218
votos sillas para lograr la mayoría y en
cuanto a gobernaciones 22 gobernaciones
han ganado los demócratas en esta
elección y 24 los republicanos hay que
Resaltar que ha habido cierta tensión en
internamente en el partido republicano
porque pues hay tropa ha salido
públicamente a criticar a medios que lo
habían apoyado durante su su sus últimos
años de política como es el Western pues
estos medios están
énfasis y están apoyando ahora aún más
Aarón de santis que se perfila como
precandidato presidencial y Donald Trump
pues ha lanzado varios ataques
públicamente al candidato y
dueño de estos medios de comunicación lo
que argumentan los republicanos
internamente es que faltó más trabajo
faltó más seguimiento en el partido
republicano y que es hora ya de dejar la
dependencia de Donald Trump como líder
del partido